[Musik]
in einem einmotorige propellerflugzeug
eine reise fast den halben erdball wer
sich unterwegs mit market balz es ist
dir 900 vierter flug über den atlantik
was ehrfurchtsvoll wird sie von ihren
kollegen königin des himmels genannt
mehr als 12.000 kilometer vier tage lang
geht es für uns in den wolken über die
schier endlosen weiten des atlantischen
ozeans und grandiose natur
[Musik]
von tap in den französischen pyrenäen
schottland nach island über grönland
hinweg nach kanada und schließlich quer
über die usa an die westküste nach
kalifornien
für viele ein abenteuer
als routine auch wenn nicht immer alles
glatt geht
der mutter dann versagt verreckt
ja das war nach fast überall nebel in
europa dann sagte der controller
meisterschaft noch ist nach mutter damit
man kann versuchen meine welche andere
chance haben sie ich hatte keine andere
chance als ich dann tatsächlich auf der
landebahn gewann endlich stehen
und bin aus dem flugzeug aus geknüpft
und saß voll auf dem boden da waren also
keine beine mehr unter werden
talisman der heilige antonius fliegt
immer mit
am morgen hatten wir uns mit magna den
taten in pyrenäen getroffen sie soll ein
flugzeug nach amerika überführen margret
ist so genannte ferry pilotin seit mehr
als 40 jahren überführt sie
kleinflugzeuge rund um den globus nach
asien afrika in die usa
niemand hat den atlantik in kleinen
propellermaschinen öfter überquert als
sie
fünf weltrekorde hat sie aufgestellt den
ersten mit 24 nonstop über den atlantik
market ist zur ikone geworden zur
königin in einer rauen männerwelt als
ich anfing haben sie gesagt lass mal
winter kommen dann ist sie sowieso
wieder weg ist wird saukalt es ist also
echten mieser job im winter manchmal
naja winter kam im winter ging ich war
immer noch da dann haben sie gehört ja
sie ist verlobt der verlobte wird schon
bald einen strich darunter setzen das
geht nicht mehr ja dann habe ich
geheiratet aber ich war immer noch da
das hört einfach nicht auf
und ja dann warte mal ab sie ist
schwanger jetzt
sind wir sie endlich los ja aber fünf
tage später saß ich da nicht dem baby im
cockpit und dann war irgendwo der punkt
dass sie sagten also ok schießbahn auf
was margaret ist auf sylt und bei bonn
aufgewachsen lebt aber seit mehr als 30
jahren in den usa liegen war schon als
kind ihr traum von nicht so niemanden
hat sie sich davon abbringen sie ist zum
vorbild geworden für viele und vieles
habe sich verändert in der branche auch
die maschinen design sehr viel sicherer
als damals heute gebe es gps und
elektronische sicherheitssysteme und
doch eine atlantiküberquerung sei immer
noch ein abenteuer meint raphael meter
vom flugzeugbauer dbm
du kommst du an einen punkt an dem du
dir überlegen musste ab wann du nicht
mehr umkehren kannst meist zwischen
grönland amerika wenn du wind schlechtes
wetter und vereisung zusammen nimmst ist
das schon eine herausforderung margret
kann euch da einiges erzählen sie war
schon oft in einer solchen situation
dieses flugzeug seien besonders sicher
aber bei einem flug über den atlantik
müsse man auf alles vorbereitet sein
meint margit
wer sind unsere überlebens anzüge das
war so eine chance haben wenn wir
wirklich ins wasser gehen würden aus
irgendeinem grund dann überleben wir
damit drei tage
ihr erster tag angenehm sagen sie
zumindest zweiter tag kühl aber kein
problem dritter tag überlebensfähig also
wahrscheinlich unterkühlt aber
lebensfähig ich kenne ein paar leute die
gerettet worden sind wir aber dann auch
den job drangegeben haben
verständlicherweise die anzug aber
bleiben erstmal eingepackt sollte der
motor ausfallen hätten wir noch etwa 20
minuten im gleitflug bis zum aufschlag
im atlantik das würde reichen um sie
noch rechtzeitig anzuziehen ich habe
also ein paar mal vorne schon angezogen
weil ich dachte es gebe ein problem ich
bin aber noch nie im wasser gewesen
die nächsten tage liegen 12.000
kilometer vor uns ein großer teil davon
über offenes meer und unbewohnte gebiete
und wir hoffen dass wir die anzüge nicht
auspacken müssen über frankreich den
ärmelkanal und england geht es rauf nach
weg an der nordküste schottlands vor der
küste ein riesiger offshore-windpark
klarer himmel es bläst ein kräftiger
wind der ordentlichen flieger rüttelt
nach viereinhalb stunden dann
landeanflug und auftanken im terminal
bleibt nur zeit für ein kurzes
schwätzchen und wir spüren freundschaft
und bewundern
sie ist sehr inspiriert sie ist so oft
über den atlantik geflogen anfangs noch
mit diesen einfachen kolbenmotoren die
konkurrenz mit den männern war damals
riesig aber mark hat sich durchgesetzt
sie ist eine der erfolgreichsten piloten
was atlantik flüge anlegt wir haben
immer viel spaß zusammen
zeit ist geld der flughafen schließt um
17 uhr wer bis dahin nicht abgehoben hat
muss extra zahlen market aber hat alles
im blick um punkt fünf uhr nils ab
schottland lassen behinderung
werden ausblick flughafen hätten mit
noch so etwas nördlich von uns die
verrühren da könnte man nach weitergehen
wenn es sein müsste aber
es ist wirklich nicht mehr die menge dar
nach knapp drei stunden über dem meer
kommt island in sicht oder besser das
was man von der insel sieht island liegt
wie fast immer unter einer dicken
wolkendecke
schade sei das meint margret denn
eigentlich wollte sie im landeanflug
rund um den vulkan fliegender märz
ausgebrochen ist aber sie zeigt uns
fotos auf ihrem handy und was uns da
jetzt entgeht sie selbst sei bei einem
der letzten zwischenstopps auf den
vulkan gekraxelt
wir landen in keflavik neun uhr abends
es war ein langer tag im flughafen
werden wir vom zoll begrüßt etwas anders
als man es sonst zu kennt
[Musik]
ich bin hier in island seit 1987 beim
zahlen ich habe am flughafen reykjavik
angefangen das ist lange her
du warst einer der ersten der man wenig
gesehen hat oh
ja erst habe ich dich hochschwanger
gesehen und dann kannst du gleich mit
einem baby wieder das war auch
unglaublich
wir übernachten auf island market plant
noch die flugroute für morgen über
grönland ganz genau immer wieder würden
sich piloten verrechnen und im wasser
landen die letzten erst vor kurzem vater
und sohn
und die waren beide gewaltig und dann
stand hier in der islamischen zeitung
den nächsten tag
amerikaner zu fett und gerettet zu
werden weil den ersten ring den sie
unter geschickt habe um die hochzurüsten
die ich auf dem bauch
am nächsten morgen wird es ernst vor uns
liegt die herausforderndste strecke über
den aktiven ozean grönland kanada in die
usa magret demonstriert uns wie wir im
notfall die überlebens anzüge anziehen
sollen ihr selbst sei einmal vor vielen
jahren mitten über dem atlantik der
motor ausgefallen ich habe dann noch
über not funk jemanden erreicht dass wir
damals panel und sagte zu dem captain
was wo was ist der mayday worauf ich
dann sagte ja also mein motor ist
ausgefallen und er sagte dann so ganz
nett welcher motor ist dann ausgefallen
denn er flog mit 747 mit vier motoren
und daraufhin sagte ich dann ziemlich ja
etwas schon erlebt oder sich mal ist ja
nun nicht gerade eine tolle situation
sagt sich dann die hat in den einen
motor den ich habe den den da vorne und
dann sagte er nur oh mein gott
ein paar hundert meter über dem wasser
aber springt der motor wieder an margrit
schafft es gerade noch nach irland wir
müssen den anzug heute nicht anziehen
können uns über der einsamkeit grönlands
der atemberaubenden eislandschaft
hingegen die habe habe sich in den
vergangenen 40 jahren stark verändert
meint mag
südgrönland sehr wie weit die gletscher
zurückgegangen sind
das sagt man sich auch wie kommt es dazu
dann gibt es eben alle möglichen
theorien dazu naja ich meine ich glaube
keiner weiß so ganz genau sicherlich es
gibt definitiv werden
klimawandel
dass sich die welt zum teil geändert
der flug über grönland in die usa mit
tankstopp in die kalorien in kanada wird
dann doch zur strapaze
nach etwa sieben stunden in der luft
stranden wir in bangor maine
gewitterfronten versperren den
weiterflug und bezahlbare hotels gibt es
keine in der amerikanischen
urlaubssaison
nach stundenlangem warten auf dem
flughafen entscheidet sich morgen zum
weiterflug sie wolle versuchen zwischen
den gewitterfronten hindurch zu fliegen
die nämlich hätten es in sich
turbulenzen möglicherweise habe es kann
ein blitzschlag geben also alle
möglichen szenarien von der seite aus
ist es also sommer einerseits gefährlich
und andererseits selbst einmal nicht
kommt dann kann man das flugzeug na ja
halb verschrotten mit jahrzehntelanger
erfahrung motiviert market sicher durch
die gewitterfronten jemand nachts nur
auf dem radar kennen kann
gegen zwei uhr morgens landen wie ein
markets heimatstadt trennten sie lädt
uns ein bei ihr zu übernachten
am nächsten morgen margrit studiert
schon die wetterkarten wird klar
mitfliegen wird es heute nicht so
gefährlich zu viele gewitter und
tornados zwischen uns und kalifornien
zeit für uns mit margaret ein bisschen
über ihr außergewöhnliches leben zu
plaudern einer der weltrekorde als
pilotin hätte ihr leben beinahe in eine
völlig andere richtung gelenkt ich komme
aus dem flugzeug heraus gehüpft und
irgendwie mann sagte dann ja sagen sie
mal wie war das denn nun mit dem flug
und können sie ein paar worte zu sagen
na ja mir viel im moment auch nichts ein
und ich fing dann an über später in
island zu reden dass eine reine
katastrophe war es war also schnee und
schneeregen und es war wahnsinniger
winter ein unheimlich tiefes in
unheimlicher tiefdruck und so und ein
paar tagen danach rief mich dann der wdr
3 jahren sagt wir haben uns das mal
angeguckt wir könnten eigentlich eine
neue wetterfee so zusammen ist auch und
jemand junges jemand dynamisch ist na ja
und dann war ich auf einmal beim wdr 3
halte sweater mädchen
ja ich kann ihn zwar keine sauna morgen
bieten obwohl es doch relativ warm
wieder wird ähnlich wie heute
temperaturen bis 10 grad also nicht ganz
happy mit der sache aber man es war auch
schwierig für eine frau in die fliegerei
einzusteigen zu meiner generation gab es
keine lufthansa pilotinnen zum beispiel
nicht dass ich unbedingt gerne linie
geflogen wäre aber ich glaube zu dem
zeitpunkt das wäre egal gewesen fliegen
fliegen fliegen fliegen ob für die linie
oder shutter oder dieser das zwar ebene
männerwelt und der einzubrechen war
nicht einfach lange aber hält sie es im
studio nicht aus flüchtet in die usa das
land der unbegrenzten möglichkeiten dort
bekommt sie die chance die sie in
deutschland so einfach nicht bekommen
hätte ich hatte es halt das glück eine
firma die mich gleich aufgenommen habe
in amerika dieser sagte das ist unsere
ferry pilot in dieser eigentlich den
reklame werte drin so unter dem motto
wenn ihr junge frau das leben kann kann
jeder das legen das ist also ein
gutmütiges flugzeug die haben das gleich
ein bisschen so ausgeschlachtet die habe
ich dann sofort angekleidet cowboy hut
und stiefel in den medien wird sie zum
vorbild für junge frauen stilisiert
margret aber will sich nicht
vereinnahmen lassen sie will fliegen und
nichts an die haben schon versucht aus
mir sagen mal diese emanze zu machen
sozusagen
das bin ich aber nicht geworden ich habe
meine fliegerei als liebe gesehen ich
habe es nicht gesehen in einem mini welt
einzubrechen und ich hab da auch wert
darauf gelegt dass ich die frau
geblieben bin ich wollte nie irgendwie
sagen ja ich bin weniger bezahlt von
sich habe ich am anfang weniger bezahlen
als die männer aber vielleicht war ich
auch noch nicht so gut ich muss dir auch
noch lernen nun am nächsten morgen geht
es für uns weiter david marcus mann
bringt uns zum flugzeug der wird war
selbst pilot ob er manchmal angst um
seine frau hätte wollen wir von ihm
wissen
ja jahrelang hatte ich angst
ich habe am telefon gewartet mehr
ausgerechnet wo sie sein müsste und dann
angerufen
und gefragt ob die wissen wo sie ist ich
hatte all die nummer
einmal sind wir mit 172 zusammen
geflogen ein langer flug über grönland
dann hat plötzlich der wind gedreht und
sie hat sich bei mir entschuldigt weil
sie geglaubt hat dass wir es wohl nicht
schaffen
das hat mir schon angst gemacht
ein bussi noch zum abschied dann geht es
für uns weiter von scranton in
pennsylvania quer über die usa nach
camarillo in
kalifornien erfahren was es heißt bei
der kleines propellerflugzeug den
naturgewalten ausgesetzt ist die
gewitter sind nämlich nicht verschwunden
das gewitter wo ich wirklich nicht
reingehen möchte weiß also schon
großer was damit andere
denn hier liegt da steht schon einige
solcher riesen profis in der reihe
zwischendurch kommt oder um den 1
das rader zeigt vor uns überall heftige
elektrische entladungen blitze in den
wolken die man mit bloßem auge bei tag
kaum erkennen kann das navigieren durch
solche wetterfronten ist türkisch selbst
für erfahrene piloten wie market weight
und uns rutscht das herz in die hose das
flugzeug wird zum spielball der
naturgewalten
nach einer gefühlten ewigkeit und
mehrfach umgedrehten eingeweihten
verstehen wir warum market
ehrfurchtsvoll die königin des himmels
genannt wird nach allem was sie schon
erlebt hat beinahe absturz und
notlandungen wollen wir von ihr wissen
was denn die außergewöhnlichste
erfahrung als pilotin gewesen sein
ich meine man sitzt im flugzeug alleine
wer soll ein beobachten aber es ging
also fast überall angstzustand ich habe
da sogar hinter den tank gebucht als
dann im kontakt mit muss bei schließlich
war fragte durch der controller ohne
dass ich das gesagt habe
ich werde etwas
ungewöhnliches gesehen hätte
nein habe ich nicht ich wollte das auch
nicht zugeben dass sie also wer welche
komischen gefühl hat er wie soll ich das
beschreiben
das passt ja keinen sinn
und als dann gelandet waren wirklich
gefragt ob ich vielleicht mal rüber
kommen könnte zum maler zentrum und dann
haben die mir also tatsächlich gezeigt
dass er ein flugobjekt
an meiner seite war für ca 10 minuten
und dann mit einer wahnsinns
geschwindigkeit beugte sich von mir
entfernt hat und verschwand und sofern
dies ist eine seltsame erfahrung aber
ich glaube würde ich bin überzeugt ich
meine wir sind nicht die einzigen
universum das oft einfach kein sehen
warum sollen wir hier 1
bestimmen welche in die intelligenter
sind als wir vielleicht schon so weit
sind
und hier unterkommen und mal gucken was
es hier gibt nicht bösartig oder hier
war sondern vielleicht ein ausflug zum
wir auf jeden fall genießen die letzten
stunden mit margit richtung kalifornien
offener see schnee und eis geht es über
die wüsten im westen amerikas zum
letzten ländern
12.000 kilometer liegen hinter uns
schönheit hans strapazen mit einer frau
die uns gezeigt hat dass man seinen
traum auch neben kann
camarillo beim flugzeug händler dann
großes empfangskomitee
und aller moderner technik ist es immer
noch etwas besonderes wenn ein so
kleines propellerflugzeug und die
piloten diese lange reise unbeschadet
überstehen
mit 64 jahren aber denkt margaret jetzt
ans aufhören sie habe ihr leben gelebt
und dabei auch sehr viel glück gehabt
das müsse man nicht überstrapazieren im
november nächsten jahres will sie
schluss machen nie wieder als pilotin in
ein flugzeug steigen das sei sie ihrem
mann schuldig
alles mitgemacht sein sein motto war
wenn sie glücklich ist bin ich glücklich
und
ich glaube es ist jetzt zeit dass ich
etwas zurückgeben er braucht es und es
nicht dass er danach fragt aber freut
sich jetzt schon auf das
war super mit euch kommt mal wieder